in the past 14 days 32 million hours of
teamfight tactics has been watched on
Twitch after 10 years raah he can
finally justify that s in their name by
releasing a carbon copy of auto chess
that even my bosses can't stop playing
so we've got this new game that kind of
looks like a card game but also
resembles a board game
and somehow it's rivaling fortnight on
Twitch it's buggy thank you
and well mostly just a copy of another
game so why the [ __ ] is is so popular
well it's fast simple building cloak by
the day and it's sexy and if I know
anything that's how you get popular on
the Internet
holy [ __ ] ok wait well alive TFT is part
of this growing roster of what people
are calling Auto bottlers which is a
[ __ ] stupid name the way these work
is their turn-based games that are kind
of like car games but also kind of like
board games where each round you pick
characters and then you more or less
watch those characters fight against
each other to see who wins the first one
was Auto chest which is actually a dota
mod and then Valve jumped in and made
their own copy and now we have TFT which
is Riots version from where I'm sitting
these games are kind of like glorified
mobile games but to me that's more of a
feature than above on paper I know it
sounds a little bit boring a game that
you're playing but not really playing
but in practice it's a lot more
addictive than you might think
traditionally there's actually even a
place for games like this on Twitch
we've been building this kind of
ecosystem where people flock to twitch
to watch these high-end eSports titles
like League of Legends and the best
players in the world play the hardest
games in the world is perfect but paired
with that are these lower intensity
games sometimes people call them like
queue games where you know you can kick
back and you get a more relaxed viewer
experience off the heels of what was
like a catastrophic failure an artifact
we had Auto chest which was this game
that was set in the dota 2 world that
everybody wanted it has that kind of
like addictive simplicity you know you
say you'd yourself man I'm gonna go to
bed right after this game you look up
and it's somehow [ __ ] 3 a.m.
quarter chest kind of felt like this
jumping-off point you know it was like
unpolished but there was clearly
something there that people were looking
for and now with dota under Lords and
team fight tactics you get these kind of
more polished charming games that take
that format and give it an opportunity
to succeed on a higher level play the
anime music wait a second he's kind of
he's kind of doing it what's the thing
that separates team fight tactics is
right gets to use the League of Legends
IP which is massive
that means tons of people are gonna be
flocking towards this game just to play
with the champions they like and leave
look it's not the dota is not popular
it's that it doesn't have the kind of
media where I pulled that League of
Legends has people will literally play
this game just to be a part of the
broader league community it's got
everything you need to succeed online
right now it's got particle effects it's
got this kind of light tone it's sort of
funny and it's got the clout of some of
gaming's biggest personalities pushing
it forward the game allows for quite a
bit of interaction and downtime so that
you can talk to your chat and make it
more entertaining in that way I like
that it crosses over so many genres it's
my first Auto boggler type of game and
because I used to play League so much I
love the nostalgia that I get from
seeing all the familiar faces and
champions so I really like that and it
has made me especially happy that
there's lots of people who haven't even
played Auto chests nor have they played
league that enjoy the game and are
addicted to it since EFT is released it
trails only the most annoying and
massive and frustrating game and get
maybe gaming history fortnight in twitch
viewership
and well at least to me those games have
a lot more in common than you might
think
for tonight's success has showed us at
the very least that you don't have to
cater towards hardcore gamers in order
to succeed in 2019
the fact is TFT and fortnight these
kinds of games allow you the ability to
turn off your brain to play a game
without getting screamed at in voice
comms for hours we're talking about a
game that to be honest it's still kind
of a mess there's still glitches
sometimes your characters just run off
the board sometimes your opponent has
five items and you have one and it's not
even at a beta I did I've done this bug
so many times look you're a degenerate
like me your Twitter feed for the last
week has been nothing but TFT obviously
team fight tactics isn't the only
mindless game on the Internet there's
literally multiple Auto chess clones
that you can be playing so what is it
that's separating this new game done by
riot from all of those other games I
already mentioned the power that the
riot IP has but to me the thing that's
most interesting about the onset of
teamfight tactics are the personalities
that have risen up to drive the game
forward of course there are the obvious
suspects the pokey mains and the scara's
the irises oh my god no these giants of
the League of Legends world that you
just know we're gonna jump on when team
five tactics came out but what's more
are some of the personalities from the
graveyard that is hearthstone eSports
past have come back and really grown
with this new type one of those
streamers is half of whose stream has
exploded as of late due to hitting rank
one of the MMR system in teamfight act
excited a game came out and you taught
myself a name in red if you'll just
throw my name in the mud and like say I
was so bad and people in washes of the
girl [ __ ] and I was only until 100
ten came out of that people like like
there are too many stats for people that
like refute it I'm so thankful there I
it for them posting it to me
joining her our personalities like theis
dog amaz [ __ ] all these heroes of our
stones past have come back to help
spearhead the game's rise they bring
with them this kind of card game charm
they're chatty and sometimes strategic
sometimes meanie but honestly never too
intense and if I'm being honest they're
my people
[Music]
you see when I'm not blabbering on
camera for the score eSports what I like
to do in my free time is play hours and
hours of Magic the Gathering and so
recently when preparing for a tournament
with my friend John I'm rambling on to
him about what decks we should play and
what decks we shouldn't play and I
realize he's not paying attention and I
hit him with the are you playing team
fight tactics and there was silence on
the other end of the line and I just
knew that motherfucker's playing tf2 you
the point I'm trying to make here is
that a few years back when eSports
started to get really popular there was
this game that was bridging the gap
between competitive and casual play nice
and its biggest names and biggest
streamers give you someone to watch
while you're eating cereal in the
morning or where you're nodding off at
night and that casual appeal that
brought people to the game that was the
same thing that allowed the games
competitive scene to throw and that
trend has continued with TFT we saw just
last week pokey main host one of the
first TFT tournaments on her channel and
in just a few short days twitch rivals
will also have TFT look I'm not trying
to tell you that this is the next great
eSport or that it's gonna use surf
fortnight and a bunch of 14 year old
kids are gonna start dancing and playing
it all day and all night what I am
trying to say is that it seems to have
rejuvenated this part of the eSports and
gaming community that I happen to love
and personally I think that's a good
sign for fans of League of Legends or
gaming in general or anyone just trying
to kill 30 minutes look I get that
there's bugs and it's mostly a clone of
auto chess and you're tilting off of the
RNG but at the end of the day I just
think it's good for gaming thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]